major news about the Clinton servers
scandal in response to a lawsuit filed
by several groups including Judicial
Watch a federal judge has ordered the
FBI to disclose more information into
how it handled the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's server joining us now
to explain more is the president of
Judicial Watch Tom Fenton all right Tom
first of all I think America owes you a
thank you for all that you've done in
your persistence because had you not
been persistent along with people like
Jay Sekulow I don't know whether or not
any of this stuff would have come out
but the latest is that a federal judges
said the FBI has to disclose information
about the investigation that they didn't
want to disclose and why don't you just
tell us specifically what that
information is well just to take a step
back we're trying to get the State
Department to work with the Justice
Department under law the federal Records
Act to go and get mrs. Clinton's emails
and take action and they're trying to
persuade the judge there's nothing else
to do and they filed the secret document
from the FBI describing what they've
done and the judge says you can't keep
this secret and I'm going to release it
and it's going to describe what the FBI
has done to date including efforts to
try to get the classified info subpoena
her internet providers and things like
that okay so it's a good ruling in the
sense that it forces the FBI to put some
more cards on the table
but the problem judge is that we're
battling the State Department and
Justice Department not there in the
Obama administration but right now over
this this ridiculous question is who
went before the federal judge and said
we don't want to hand out any
information about the FBI's
investigation into Hillary's server the
Justice Department or the State
Department all the State Department's
the defendant and their represented by
Justice Department lawyers okay so you
have a twofer on the deep state here
okay and that's where I'm going we're
talking about the deep sate here we've
got a federal judge saying you're both
wrong Justice Department and State
Department but we've got Jeff Sessions
and we thought Rex Tillerson who are
charge of those departments and I would
suspect Tom and when I was a DA myself
they don't go into court without talking
to me about major cases so what am I
missing here is that the deep Seder is
in sessions and Tillison who is
objecting to this
well the deep state is a big issue I
mean if if left to operate on its own
it's going to object it's going to
obstruct it's going to protect Hillary
Clinton in the Obama administration and
that's why the head of the agencies like
secretary Tillerson and the Attorney
General IRS's designee need to get these
bureaucrats under control and start
releasing this information you know I'm
pretty sure that President Trump doesn't
want to be spending taxpayer resources
defending Hillary Clinton we're trying
to get the email she delete a judge and
we're facing a fight from the Trump
administration's appointees and agencies
it's something that is so frustrating
it's one thing that faced this during
the Obama administration now it'll boy
all right well Tom thanks for all the
work you're doing and thank goodness for
this judge and coming up see